Hi, I'm Przemek.
This is Agnieszka.
We're from Migam, and we
try to make life easier
for our deaf community
around the world.
We have two main products.
One of those is already working
and have a lot of customers.
It's a translation system when
we use video for interpreting.
And second one, we
have a working beta.
This is automatic
translation system,
and we use kinetic camera
and neural networks,
and we build system that
is able to translate sign
language automatically,
and the other side.
Biggest challenge for us
is to get enough quality
data, because for
the last 40 years,
different teams from
different countries
try to build system that will
be able to translate sign
language into spoken language.
And it's possible
now, because now there
is camera such as
kinetic camera.
There is devices like
[INAUDIBLE] or [INAUDIBLE].
These devices give
us information
about 3-D. Information
about the deaf.
We use this data
to map, especially
at points about human body.
And we can recognize the
fingers and the face,
and recalibrate all
the data and this
is the input for
our internal brains.
What is very important for us
is the fact that, to communicate
with deaf people,
the paper and the pen
is not enough, because
a lot of deaf people
have problem with
understanding the written text
because the native
language is sign language.
They have totally
different grammar.
This is just a
different language.
For example, in Poland, Polish
language is very hard to learn.
And for deaf people
who live in Poland,
it's much easier to learn
English than Polish.
That's why this
is a big challenge
to communicate with deaf
using only paper and the pen.
Our system, we help them
to improve communication
in every day.